good morning guys just finished working
out and today is a crazy
exciting day
do you want to tell them why mama
[Music]
because
we're filming our first episode of our
podcast our very first episode whoa yeah
and i'm half dead um no it's super
exciting because it's been as you guys
uh know if you've been following we've
been talking about rebranding and read
this and read that and we're like wait
our podcast room's gonna be different
and finally
finally
after like three months i think longer
probably we're finally shooting our
first episode um we're gonna stockpile a
lot of these episodes for you guys we're
gonna get some good quality content and
then we'll make it live so you can look
forward to um listening to the new
podcast within the next
few weeks do you wanna tell them the
name of our podcast
the name of our podcast yeah
get close
and our very first guest today is
anthony
and it makes so much sense in terms of
like
a beautiful
i guess well-rounded story because when
we first started our bail cast our our
first podcast and we were shooting at
the old jk office remember that set
we're on my marine corps flag and all
that
his episode was so heartfelt we were
laughing we were crying we've been doing
youtube together for over 10 years
together
and for some reason that episode the
file got corrupted like the audio wasn't
working or the video wasn't working with
him so it's the only episode that never
aired
so we thought
the only way
to kick off this podcast is to honor it
with our good friend and brother
anthony lee
all right just got dressed
kind of exciting
because i never
really get dressed for jk because it's
such a circus show you know it's just
like everyone come in with the epitome
of your personality so joe's shirtless
with a cape of course with long samurai
hair
uh steve comes in with krypto and colts
gear i come in looking like i'm about to
work out
anthony comes in looking steez out every
single time
but for our get close podcast we're
trying to make the branding like a
little bit more
uh intimate a little bit more serious
not so goofing around really diving deep
you know like the videos aren't 10
minutes long they're gonna be hour long
podcasts and really want to get to know
the guests we want to get close with the
guests which is why that's the name
so i want to present myself in that way
i'm in mauber's closet right now to show
you what i look like it's got like a
little
sky blue button up on
with some shoes a little pop blue some
little khaki khakis a little tan leather
watch
i am not used to wearing clothes i'll
tell you that much because i am sweating
my freaking ass off yeah so now i'm
gonna head over to the podcast room
uh get ready go over some notes because
yes we're taking it professionally
but i am it is hard to resist to not
play some drums for five seconds
so i'll play a little bit of drums and
then what's funny and then i go over
some notes on my beard
[Music]
okay
look
who has finally arrived
one of those that kept tickling me and i
didn't want to sneeze during the podcast
i was like i'm gonna get you out of here
like this
don't be jealous of my man
look at that oh [ __ ] oh
all right anthony welcome to our house
dude
shoot look at this guy it's halloween
time for the kids
this was 50 grand [ __ ] you
no way dude
look at that watch our touch
bam
why is it making funny noises hey
hey how come hey what the hell
see
see what see what i'm telling you
hey what the [ __ ]
hey dude see this is what i'm telling
you dude this is what happens when you
try to do baller [ __ ] but then you have
chinese brain yeah how many thousands of
dollars you spend for those ones to not
work at the same time i know what the
[ __ ] is that dude
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh dude
it's like getting a lambo and then one
of the windows don't go up like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but it's kind of tight if you use your
imagination
yeah
oh yeah this is where you guys would
have done the bang bang boogies
next time you guys could come and do the
bang bang boogies here oh yeah dang we
totally could have had sex in here yep
and we won't even hear you guys whoa we
could have sex all over the place
that's so cute yeah we got it for our
family because um
we want to be able to have like families
just come and stay with us so you could
sleep one two three four five six like
six people oh
yeah there's no mattress in there though
oh yeah yeah you tried yep
but you guys could've boogied up in here
yo it's not funny seeing like giant ass
houses and then like three percent
covered in halloween festivities
hey we tried dude
it's pretty cute it is cute yeah
i like it i like that they're still
doing stuff halloween isn't even my
season so
really yeah do you like coloring you
sure this is a bedroom
i know
it's so stupid it's
it's really sweet no it's ty what are
you talking about this is like a six
imagine young bar in this house that
roll parties here oh hell yeah dude
people just get lost and wake up in the
closet somewhere yo hey you want to go
in the bathtub yeah closets
oh
dang dude medieval
yeah that's pretty cool
yo first of all a box for every shoe
for rails
you don't do that
real estate man real estate oh okay you
gotta you gotta have the real estate but
yes hang our pants a box fort
don't hate don't hang our pants first
look at this my closet's messy we're
still moving okay don't judge me this is
his closet yeah wow dude i love that you
have so much
clothes that i don't wear
oh
no clothes i just wear barbell stuff all
the time yeah i'm surprised that you
even [ __ ] have nice clothes outside
of like three outfits a year
you're so happy with that disc
i like clothes but i just sweat dude i
sweat too much this is our little office
dude
it's kind of cool huh that's where you
work we do a little
a little tag team action right here this
is so [ __ ] up
whose desk
this whole side looks messy as [ __ ] i
know
so lower your expectations
but you're also
the very first person in real life to
see our podcast room
you're our first guest
all kinds of [ __ ] and we built it with
our bare hands
continuing carpet what is this
the audio sounds like it's already be
nice to us actually sounds pretty good
oh
we built it ourselves dude
oh [ __ ]
thank you we built everything ourselves
what yeah
like that was a window we covered it so
it looks like a studio there was a
window here we covered it even here
there's a window we covered it that's
why you see this weird little bump but
you don't see it on camera yeah it is a
weird little bump but we're like [ __ ] it
would you guys just [ __ ] up on that side
everywhere
yeah
yeah we did everything around all the
wires did all the labeling all that
stuff built these shelves looks like you
guys ran the wires yourself
hey dude that's messed up i'll just
describe it that's [ __ ] up dude
yeah yeah you guys should see our
podcaster
and that we put a fake fireplace so it
looks like it's a living room but it's
not that sick as [ __ ]
it's not even plugged in
are you guys painting no you're not
painting no i'm not painting i like this
i like this roller i built this from
scratch pretty cool huh yeah yeah
those are all his favorite things
hey you put lights under that stick yeah
i i wired it i did everything dude
thanks man yeah i feel like you're our
parents in relation to you i i did all
the lighting on that shelf too i had to
run the wires and do all kinds of stuff
is that is that boy scout that thing's
over 20 years old that's your actual one
my actual one i gotta find mine it's 20
years old dude i can remember that hell
yeah vhs bloodsport yep
hell yeah dude
yeah we need to throw [ __ ] it's like my
childhood right here i can understand
why we're friends yep drumline martial
arts i can also understand why you're
attacking his father boys why why why
why what do you say
writing joke now on jk is when worlds
like you are that is tyka's father she's
always like saying she crazy [ __ ] is
like your tigers everybody's always like
that's such a bart thing to do like
there's no there's no difference between
your lineage it's really just anything
that you think is crazy it's definitely
from yourself which is cool
all right guys
i choked on a protein pop they're really
chalky
but anyways monumental moment here
first time rolling with a guest
don't laugh at me don't laugh at me
all right sound speech
there we go
this is like our conversation
all three are working
excuse me there we go
super
camera speeds
close up on anthony
camera speeds
damn we're speeding all these cameras
oh by the way um if you're the one that
keeps telling us we got it i'm giving
him i'm gonna give him literal no little
creative direction literally he'll be
like are you guys ready and we're like
yes and then he goes oh hold up i gotta
do this this this and then you have a
conversation damn you're still 500
feisty thank you baby
um when you
when you need to look at the camera
anthony this is your camera not the one
with the blue tape okay
the blue tape is the wide
so if you do need to speak into camera
it's the not blue tape okay the one in
the farthest back yes okay got it camera
speeds on this one
yeah i was like
oh [ __ ] not that long what's cause the
blue is for everyone to know
and then last camera
i hate how much i love this man
i'm already disgusted what are you
talking about
can uh
anthony can you give a nice little clap
action thick one
we finished a very
very successful
very close
and
personal
podcast
with
anthony um and he left you can almost
say that we
were able to get close
oh my god i knew it i knew that look was
gonna be there
but yeah we picked up the young monkey
dude
yep
we picked up the young monkey dude
and we were gonna go to the park but it
looks like it just might sprinkle
so for sprinkles we might get snuggled
up and just hang out
on the couch because it is couch weather
like snuggly weather look at the sky
look at that
wait let me change the settings on the
camera so you can see
that's what i'm seeing
super blue looking
lots of clouds
oh that looks crazy
what are you making them hot choc hot
choc hot cocoa
hot chocolate
are you cold mister
you're cold dude
[Music]
he likes putting sprinkles in it for
some odd reason go cue me
here
missy can i help you hold it
oh
[Music]
you're cold monkey let's go i'll take
the chocolate
what in the world is going on
wait what happened
that's what it's called monkey it's
called hot cocoa because it's supposed
to be hot
it's not gonna burn you here
how come i only see two blankets how
come there's not three blankets okay you
don't wanna
i wanna snuggle you know me i'm a
snuggle
the snugglemaster control for what
[Music]
for your truck
oh he's even care he has a remote
control where is your truck oh there it
is oh my goodness
there's your truck dude
you're gonna play with the remote
control from the blankets
are you kidding me
that is your son that's some [ __ ] i
would do
the apple yeah fall too far from the
tree
the cuckoo tree it's true
we decided to ride our bikes to the park
because the weather's so awesome
that goes in this big jacket that mama
just bought them
so i can grow into it oh yeah and mama
is oh my god is your hand hurt holding
the
bar for sure
mama's in the full can just get up so
this guy has diarrhea right now right
yeah tell me everything tell me all that
she's making he's not familiar with
diarrhea so he's like mom i have a lot
of poo poo yeah cause he felt it all
come out yeah and you know when you have
a lot of diarrhea the acid from your
stomach yeah start turning your butt
hole that burns a little butt but now
we're outside and
don't say that yeah it sounds so bad
that sounds really bad i'm like dude you
just have diarrhea don't say it out loud
yeah you can't come running out of the
house screaming my little butt butt
hurts
what are you saying dude
how's your butt feel
okay okay well there's a park over there
and the stuff's not gonna play by itself
i need someone to go play on it okay
i'm not going how are you going to walk
you can even do any physical activity
no inactivity is the number one cause of
diabetes in this country don't you know
that
[Music]
okay
up next is
the mexican
specimen they're so funny way in
weighing in at
150
pounds
511 we have the next
tarzan from guadalajara go
what
that's fun huh kid stuff is fun
excuse me
right
a part of me
is kind of sad
and a part of me is happy
the sad part is that this kid is
literally growing up right in front of
me but the happy part is he could do
stuff like this by himself look all by
himself whoa
that's freaking awesome
good job dude
when we first moved here i had to lift
them up every single time
but then now he could do it by himself
and he's just growing up he has these
arm muscles they can do pull-ups and all
that it's amazing
what did you want monkey
my turn okay
okay
all right count it off tycho
[Music]
all right so taika is gonna go to his
room
and get his pajamas
because his tum tum still doesn't feel
that good
we literally saw him the other day at
jiu jitsu class like as he was playing
he smelled his finger after touching the
mat and licked it
and then the other day
we're at the park and we're playing
and then he was playing on the handle
bars and stuff
and he comes home and he licks it
so he keeps getting these little tummy
aches and keep telling him
he can't be like touching dirty things
and licking his hands
but it's also hard because i was one of
those kids that love playing on the
metal monkey bars
and i love licking my hands after
because i love the salty taste
so he is my son
and he's not feeling that good so even
though it's 7 30
we're gonna just probably put him to bed
early and hopefully he feels better
tomorrow but he he i know he's not
milking it because he has been having
diarrhea
and when he has diarrhea he wants me to
go wipe his butt even though he knows
how because it burns
so um i hope this little time times
feels good tomorrow but thank you guys
for kicking it with us and thank you
guys for watching us
debut and record our first ever get
close podcast i hope you guys like it um
yeah we're completely trying to revamp
the whole thing
we're gonna try to always have a guest
on and uh
each time the guest comes on we have
different themes like fan submitted
questions
we have a segment called truth or donate
yeah so i think this will be really
really cool all right good night